(sighs)
- Anything?
- No.
- Look, man.
I know you just had a
really bad brain injury
and you can't remember anything,
but this is our old bar.
We used to come here once a week.
So, tonight,
let's just try to have a fun time
and hopefully you could
just jog your memory
and you can get back to
being the old you, okay?
That sounds good, man.
Hey, it's Jeff right?
- Yeah, Jeff.
This is the bar.
- Wow.
- You don't remember?
You would always buy
two shots of tequila for us?
- I would?
- My best friend doesn't remember me.
- No, no, no, no, no!
I do!
Yeah, we'll take two shots of tequila!
- Top shelf tequila.
We would always do top shelf because
we're top shelf friends?
And there's our favorite
song that you won't remember.
I wish I could buy it right now
but I'm a little strapped for cash.
- Oh, no.
- Yeah.
You know when you were in your coma
I was paying for your rent
and your insurance
and your car payment
and
I was taking your girlfriend out cause
she's just been a mess, you know?
Anything to distract her, you know.
A little dinner here,
a little movie there,
a little dancing, it just
it all adds up.
- Well how much do I owe you?
- No, no man.
We're friends.
You don't owe me anything.
- I mean, seriously.
- It was 2877 dollars.
No.
- No.
Let me pay you back.
- We're friends, no.
- Please, please!
Do you have
(mumbles)
- I do.
I guess.
- Look, I think that
girl's checking me out.
- You know, you don't, you don't
like girls
anymore,
remember?
- Wait, what?
- Yeah.
You told me like right
before the accident,
that you were just kind of done.
Yeah.
- But what about my girlfriend?
- You said that you were
gonna break up with her.
You just haven't told her yet.
Yeah.
So, you know what I'm going to do.
I'm going to go over there and just
talk to her,
probably get her number
because I don't want you going over there
and just getting even
more confused, you know?
I'm doing this for you so,
I'll be over there
and then you can
you can talk to that guy.
That guy's your type, right?
- Justin?
Justin?
It's me, Jeff.
Your best friend, Jeff,
like
there was a crazy guy that
kidnapped you from the hospital.
- You know what?
My real best friend Jeff warned me
that you would come here
and try to impersonate him.
(grunts)
Disgusting.
- Whoa, whoa!
What was that?
Just some guy trying to
take advantage of me.
- Oh.
- Hey, ready for me to
buy you that new car?
- Well, you did promise it
to me before your injury.
(laughs)
- Right.
It's all coming back to me!
(upbeat music)